it's tough now to even to know what
conservative means because I have so
many friends of mine who were you know
liberals Democrats and they tell me you
know like they like glue I believe the
same exact things I believed five years
ago but for some reason if I talk about
them I'm worried that I'm going to get
in trouble so it's sort of like people
are being and kind of pushed into the
conservative you know the conservative
bent or whatever that or the being
labeled ISKCON every label those
conservatives without even considering
themselves conservatives there's a lot
of work that I've done in the past like
I got my first job out of out of college
I wrote erotic fiction for a living I
wrote a dirty stories for a living like
that was my first job that's not really
a job that I would say that conservative
would really take you know writing so I
can't believe like there's no reason for
me to bring that up there's a case the
comedy thing doesn't work don't
everybody to know that I could go that
route again
yeah and write dirty stories that's the
only reason you've come in trigonometry
you want you want you wanted some jobs
doing that exactly my erotic fiction
career needs to be picked up yeah it's
funny that you say that because we have
a kind of more libertarian comedian in
this country Simon Evans who used to
write pornography for this yeah yeah and
so maybe that's why you kind of said
you're a libertarian which no one in the
UK knows what it means but it means
you're problematic very very problematic
well even in the United States you know
libertarians you know people don't
necessarily know what that it so you'll
I think sometimes the libertarians will
be labeled Republicans who smoke weed
which is a you know like a very like
over simple simplified way of putting it
for me as a as a small L libertarian I'm
not a part of a the libertarian party my
whole thing comes down to this idea of a
voluntary exchange between between
people that I don't want any initiation
of force I don't want people forcing
others to do their
do their bidding and I sort of take that
from the personal you know the personal
place between this is all voluntary and
then sort of expand that to you know
groups and etc etc and a lot of times
that includes if for the most part
things like you know smaller government
and rights as far as what you can and
cannot put in your body the idea is if
you're not hurting anybody else you
should be able to put whatever you like
in your body that's sort of thing and
what would challenges do you face when
it comes to rights in political comedy
because - right for instance a Trump
joke is phenomenally difficult because
there's so many people like you said
going after the same
terrain yeah I think it I think it's
like anything you know being original is
the is a tough part point and then also
being able to do a joke and not lose the
audience right from the get-go so
sometimes there'll be videos that that
we put out and people like oh this is
just right-wing propaganda and it's like
why I didn't really consider it
right-wing propaganda I thought it was
me taking an idea and developing it and
and trying to do something with it and
then other times though I you know will
be called you know you Lib tardes which
is do you guys have a Lib tardes here
and I actually I want to take that back
for libertarian yeah like I wanted a lip
tarde to be the libertarian thing it's
not working out well in in the US but
it's funny it's like depending on which
if you if you have a if you have a weird
nuanced view of the world I think people
are so used to you know everybody sort
of being in a box where if you believe
this you must believe this this and this
therefore I can see one thing that you
did over here and make all these
sweeping assumptions about where you
fall on these other political issues
[Music]